all right we have this story from axios
phoenix
lake declares victory in arizona gop
primary says outstanding ballots will
favor her with at least 150 000 votes
left to count carrie lake declared
victory wednesday in the republican
primary for governor while rival karen
taylor robson stayed mum throughout the
day
lake led robson by less than two
percentage points and as of wednesday
morning but the remaining ballots which
are largely early ballots that were
dropped off at polling places on
election day are expected to expand her
lead okay i say the ap hasn't called the
race yet but look
even though they're they're early
ballots they're still saying it's likely
gonna be for carrier lake but let me
show you this uh let me see if i have
the maps here check this out did we just
get an update i think we just got an
update literally right now
still that's still 80 it's been 80
percent
new york times they've been calling it
80 all day yeah take a look at this
right here we can see taylor robson in
the in maricopa she's got it but the
rest of the state is for carrie lake how
is it this close
i think there's a simple answer
democrats are voting as republicans in
the in the republican primary
and that way
it's certainly possible i mean why not
do a crossover but then they're not
going to be able to vote democrat in the
democratic party the democrat primary
was today too and if
if you scroll up if you look at the
democrat primary um what do i say katie
hobbs yeah katie hobbs had
all of the state except for was it santa
cruz county there at the bottom santa
cruz county yeah that's it so it's not
like there was a big contentious race on
the democrat side it's almost you were
gonna yeah it's a question of like if
you they think it's more effective to
try and put a more extreme candidate in
office we've all talked with us they
think that they can beat carrie lake
later
you know
these notes yeah it's a better gamble to
uh
vote in the republican primary i guess i
mean not all states have open primaries
like this and some if you're registered
as a democrat you can only participate
in the democratic primary that's true in
new york yeah new york stream
connecticut nevada i think is changing
this law and the idea because they're
talking about like uh rank choice
rank choice voting yeah we have ranked
choice voting in new york in new york
city but um you can still only vote in
your
designated party primary oh yeah
with these people if they
now
like are they still registered democrat
while they're voting in the republican
primary you have to change your
registration most likely can they do
that like and then the next day change
it back or they stuck it for a year as
like a republican now
i don't know what the rules are about
registering that's like such local stuff
i don't know yeah there's huge varieties
some places you have to
be registered for a certain period of
time prior to like before you know who
the candidates are no they've known who
the candidates are for a long time
carrie lake was running for governor
starting in january so i think they i
think you probably could have changed it
before it's an open primary mm-hmm oh
it's an open priority so even if they're
registered as a democrat they can
participate in the republican primary
wow
that's kind of crazy maybe we shouldn't
allow that yeah i don't know that why
would you have that one the argument
against it is or the argument against it
is typically that independents can't
participate in the primary so nevada has
a high proportion of independent voters
and they think
leaving the closed primary system would
be better because they would have they
would be able to participate in
narrowing down the candidates earlier on
take a look at this over at the new york
times article you can see 482 113 votes
in the democratic primary 637
210 in the republican party but for some
reason
it's the maricopa area that's gone for
karen taylor robson and not carrie lake
maybe it's crossover i'm not entirely
convinced it may just be
moderate leaning republicans are like
where do i want the maga stuff so that's
probably true yeah right in the cities
there are more
moderates yeah i mean but are these
people going to come out for pence isn't
he talking about making though
i don't know about that he's the
milkiest of the milk toasts you know but
i'll i'll add this
if these numbers are correct and that at
637 000 republicans came out to vote
democrats are in serious trouble serious
trouble
if it's true that democrats switched
over because we've seen that reported in
certain in other instances then
republicans are going to be blindsided
because if how many how many of these
would you need to take away take away a
hundred thousand of these votes and then
all of a sudden the democrats are
winning yeah or not quite or yeah
actually yeah they would be winning i
don't i don't believe that a hundred
thousand people came out and were
democrats voting to sabotage carry a
lake it's possible i think it's probably
just simply put
urban conservative types are middle of
the road but i think they might have
been hard to believe and we might have
seen like the you know arizona
democratic party making the suggestion
people aren't good at keeping these kind
of secrets so if it was a suggestion
we would have seen it on social media
i mean look megan mccain's got fans and
she was ripping into carrie lagoon she
was so mad about it but the other thing
is that i pulled the real clear politics
poll numbers i mean carrie lake has been
popular she has been leading the polls
for several weeks at this point so in
some ways you know maybe people did
cross over and on the other hand you
would assume there'd be some indication
that she is maybe more popular than
arizona is willing to admit to itself
well that that makes sense i mean if
they're polling people you get a phone
call and you're like who are you voting
for someone who hates carrie lake is
gonna be like not carry a lake but
someone who's crossing over to sabotage
carrie lee like will contribute to a
vote against her so
you know if if they get called up it's a
democrat are you voting for karen taylor
robson they're saying no way
but they do vote in the primary to
sabotage carry league that someone could
be i'm a democratic registered democrat
but i'm going to vote in the republican
primary for the crappier candidate and
then i'm going to switch back and vote
for the democratic agenda but this is an
open this is an open primary take a look
at this story so i guess can you if it's
an open primary can you show up and say
you want one ballot instead of another
or is everybody on the same ballot i
don't know
how would they prevent you from voting
twice it could explain why a bunch of uh
well here's the other issue too
now
this is the weird thing people are
pointing out like it's very strange that
kerry lake was doing so well in the
polls
what about every other candidate in in
arizona look at this blake masters
wins swimmingly
so all of these trump endorsed
candidates
sweep through with no questions
but then kerry lake is
and it's not just about arizona it's
like all these states gibbs in michigan
i think it's michigan right trump
endorsed wins with the help from
democrats a lot of help from democrats
that was so weird that was so
interesting because they were
putting in money
democrats were putting money in to get
gibbs the victory there and this is the
strategy
um this is a strategy i was listening to
this podcast today the new york times
podcast actually um about how claire
mccaskill was the one who really
pioneered this strategy of essentially
picking the candidate that she wanted to
run against and then
putting like putting up ads that made
that candidate popular to the far right
so she looked at the spate of candidates
in missouri
um decided that she wanted to run
against this one guy who seemed crazy
who would eventually ended up being the
one who said that if a woman is raped
she can shut that down and then not get
pregnant remember that guy yeah
everybody have a way has a way of
shutting that down right because of
course sure you know every woman knows
you've got like a trap door yeah
this is a basic human biology i don't
know what you guys think you see star
wars you know guys you know
for some guys those medieval monks were
correct with the teeth you know you can
shut it down is that what that sorry you
remember the medieval monk i remember oh
yeah yeah
sounds awesome you guys we were in a
different health lesson
by gender i did see that movie teeth
oh god no have you ever seen it
actually in a play that i wrote this one
time uh one of the characters how are we
talking about this now
anyway this karen lake made us do this
one character she said if i had teeth
down there i'd have bit his hand off
have you there's a movie called tv
pleased to meet them and they're like
this woman goes to the doctor to like
the gyno and he's like let me just check
you up and then his hand gets mutilated
and he's like vagina dentata
and then she's like
yeah that's the movie it's like i guess
a horror movie i had a friend who was
obsessed with that and he also would
that's a totally different story anyways
it was claire mccaskill
she went with this thing uh and she was
running ads that was like you know this
person is really opposite and she made
him really popular to the far right and
that is a strategy that they used to to
pump gibbs and also we all remember when
trump was running against hillary
clinton and everyone was like oh it'll
be great if trump gets the gop
nomination because hillary clinton will
have no trouble beating him you know
this is a stupid this is a stupid
maneuver guys you know like go with your
values
you believe in who you would think would
be positive and good leaders for our
country absolutely not no that's against
the rules november of 2016 one of the
greatest years ever
was just seeing the establishment
have everything implode the panic the
crying it was insane it was it was like
schadenfreude but just like uh like the
most
dense
hyper concentrated straight into the
vein
intravenous schadenfreude watching all
these people lose their minds i will say
i was one of the sad people and i went
to
whole foods no i went to fairway i went
to fairway in brooklyn the next day
which is this like extremely yuppy
grocery store
and there were people crying like
sobbing as they were picking out their
frozen vegan waffles and then sweet home
alabama came on like over the pa system
this older woman walked up to like one
of the people who worked there and said
now i really think this is in very poor
taste can we at least change this
my stepmom has a story about dropping
her kids off at montessori like school
or whatever and these moms sobbing and
one is like does someone have a snack to
give to jim like i did i couldn't pack
one this morning you're like girl get it
together yeah it feels like you know you
can still feed your kids but i remember
people calling out of work with with
like sadness just calling like i mean
going into morning it was
so you know i was hanging out with her
and it's just it's fun to reminisce
about some of the greatest days in human
history right but uh november 2nd 2016.
it's one of those was it no it was it
was the 11th was it no it's ninth it was
the ninth what when they what do you
mean november 9th is when trump won was
seven
it was early november we can agree it
was before the 15th cold day
november 8th
there we go number eight everybody's
wrong i'm happy no but the ninth was
when they called it for him
the ninth is when he was dead
they did declare after midnight so tim
is technically correct here he's like
i'm talking about everybody crying it's
november 9th yeah
uh okay so i'll take technically correct
but it reminds me of that meme where the
two women go like
and the guy just goes yeah
you know what i'm talking about there's
like two women and they look at
something and they're like shocked and
the guy just starts laughing and smiling
that's what it was like i didn't vote
for him but it was just like to see
hillary clinton just see everything that
she's ever wanted taken from her and
she's such a just an awful person it was
just wilderness it was so amazing it
just it was euphoria you know yeah i was
it was totally crazy i remember how many
people around me were just
like it was completely divided as what i
remember even people who weren't that
political were suddenly like i don't
know what's gonna happen to the country
and the people i had no idea were in any
way interested in politics also being
like this is the best thing ever like
well so i had no idea so bringing it
back to where we are now with you know
like carrie lake and all that stuff now
i'm just like okay look you know i voted
for trump in 2020 i think school choice
was really really important he was all
about it and looking now at arizona with
kerry lake um
the possibility is that the whole system
is just is completely imploded
like democrats so look the atlanta
general constitution wrote democrats are
voting in gop primaries say it's all
about donald trump this article talks
about how was it 16 000 voters who chose
democratic ballots were among the 237
who voted in the gop primary now it's
possible i argued they just switched
parties
they've abandoned the democrats that's a
reality right maybe what we're seeing in
arizona is that tons of democrats are
like i don't want the democrats i don't
want the maga and so there are they are
legitimately trying to vote republican
and it's just it's left more
left-leaning people joining the
republican party
the same time
democrats are funding trump-supported
trump endorsed candidates so the
democratic officials are are propping up
trump's endorsed candidates while the
voters are voting for the other moderate
republican candidate or whatever they
want to call them it's just the whole
system is brought is busted oh we
watched it no go ahead oh it's just like
larry hogan got really mad about this
too he was like democrats are fun i mean
it was like what one point it was like
over a million dollars for 1.2 million
or something right and they got funded
in and he was like this is democrat
interference in our election like this
this is not good and i
don't
think that it matters to them like even
if the strategy is you could argue what
got donald trump elected which i don't
think it is but it played a role in some
part in some ways it's not working for
them i don't understand why you would
keep doing it well we did watch them
change the rules right like it was after
the 2016 election
and we watched everyone freak out
because trump had won and decide that
this was a huge crisis and that now it
didn't matter what you had what what you
did so long as you were resisting
remember resist and it was like i
remember watching that and i was like
resist what though you guys like what is
it that we are going to resist
or like with obama change well what do
you want to change really and what do
you want to change it to like define
your terms so that we can actually talk
about what's going on but with the whole
resist thing it was anything trump
anything trump did was completely wrong
and had to be stopped at all costs
remember that
and they proceeded that way through now
i had friends tell me that using like
violent fascist tendencies against your
enemy if trump for whatever was fine i'm
like dude that's insane right you cannot
take on evil and become evil to destroy
evil just creating more but that's what
that's the decision that was made was
that this is a crisis rules don't matter
common decency doesn't matter we have to
give up every the ways that we've
behaved up to this point you know that
was what they did i'm just so tired of
you all the people that cried
when donald trump won
those the people that i'm i'm just i i
am sick of and and you know like tucker
crosston pointed out when uh i think it
was ben smith asked if he was racist
that was a great interview yeah he was
like the people that i don't like are
like middle-aged white liberal women
he's like i blamed him for everything
yeah he's like that's the one that's not
racist
um
that they are an overwhelming major uh
an overwhelmingly large block of
democrat voters so you look at this
group they're crying they have no idea
what they're crying about oh the mean
man said naughty words dude when you've
got
murderous dictators communist regimes
outright fascists are they called
trumpet fascists but come on he's not
and they're actually threatening us
you might want the potty mouth bully guy
to go in there and you know shove
someone around and be like back off i
that was the thing i liked about trump
you know trump is as i've said before
he's the crazy guy on a corner with a
knife you stay away from him
you keep your distance your house never
gets right it's okay
like all of all of the buildings on the
street are just like vandalized and
looted but there's one really nice one
yours is fine and they're just like how
come no one's robbing this building it
was a crazy guy on the corner with a
knife i just keep feeding them steaks
it's fine it works out one way to keep
on like when he said he was gonna nuke
beijing or moscow do you remember that
and nobody and you don't know he might
he just might that's the thing with
biden now right like biden is a dotty
old man and you have absolutely no
confidence that he's going to do
anything other than the most moderate
conciliatory
uh weak-ass move
yeah i think he'll just be totally in
line i mean
i don't mean to kick him while he's down
but like this guy got coveted after just
getting coded like i don't really think
he's like signing executive orders while
locked in his bedroom he's grounded like
i
i don't know that uh
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there